the more regenerative i get and think of
soil health and resistance approach
rather than a product approach my
herbicide bill's gone down by half my
fungicide bill's gone down by 40
my fertilizer bill cut by half
[Music]
i want to get away from using artificial
nitrogen in a few years
by having a systems approach building on
soil health benefits
building fertility a natural processes
within my farming system the future's
got to be that way because
artificial fertilizer is going to be a
limited resource
diesel will be a limited resource we
will move away from these
fossil based products to more
nature-based products
we cannot continually mining phosphate
and potash out of the ground
it's not renewable so how the heck do we
find a farming system
that actually allows us to produce
enough food to feed the global
population
but also have enough effect and benefit
to the to the soil and the system around
it
[Music]
the conservation agriculture direct
drilling system for myself at the moment
is a time thing
it's meant that i could take on this
farm three years ago and
and farm it the area with a lot less
people and a lot less machinery and
capital outlay
in terms of machinery than would have
been possible 10 or 15 years ago
i'm not doing it because i believe this
is well i know that this is going to
make me more money than another way of
doing it
i'm doing it because i don't want to
have to go out and buy lots of
big cultivators and big horsepower
tractors and have a
massive regular diesel tank in the yard
that i need to fill up every week
i want to be able to farm the area i'm
farming better
be more weather resilient with less
machinery
and every day that if i can turn up in
this field drill it
leave come back six weeks later and
drill my cash crop and go away again
all that time in the middle i can have
off i could either not be at work all
the time every hour of the day on the
tractor
or i can go and do some work somewhere
else either on another field
on the farm or farm or a larger area
myself or for
contracting customers
on average these tractors now do about
150 160 hours a year
farming conventionally we would put
certainly 800 hours a year on a tractor
and sometimes a thousand hours a year
wouldn't be unusual so these tractors
are probably
only doing through the year 20 of the
work
that they would have been doing before
from stubble to stubble
so including planting our catch or cover
crops the whole establishment and
looking after the crops through the year
including harvesting
we would now use the maximum of 40 41
litres
a hectare and in the past we would have
been using
certainly to possibly three times as
much as that
and and certainly work that i've done
with a series of customers
for uh a supply chain contract in the
past
the range of fuel use ran from 40 liters
a hectare to
160 liters a hectare in the extreme so
the potential is certainly to halve your
fuel use
possibly more than that and in the
extreme the fuel use would be around a
quarter of what it could be
on some soil types